Sounds like I'm in Pokemon.
Sounds like a Pokemon OST.
Oh my gosh.
Like it's so epic.
Thank you for 7 months.
It's my friend and fellow wisp Melpy's birthday.
You can say happy birthday.
I'm sure she'll pass out when she catches the bod later.
Happy birthday Mel.
You're such a nice friend.
Of course I can say happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Melpy.
Happy birthday.
I like how you got it in right at the beginning of the stream.
So it's just like...
If she skips the intro...
Well, no.
You start the stream and you're like, yeah.
That's it.
Yo, welcome to membership.
We love when Mint does the Mint thing.
Oh my gosh, another birthday.
I finally got a job and my first day was yesterday.
Daddy!
Oh my gosh!
The music got so epic for you.
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Daddy Inferno.
Happy birthday.
Welcome everybody to Cookie Yummy 4.
I...
I've only played the first one.
I can't imagine.
It's so much different.
I went to an Indian restaurant once in Japan and they gave me some kind of flatbread.
I asked them, 何ですか?
For some reason they kept saying, はい、そうです。
Like the not...
何ですか?
はい、そうです。
That is good.
That's a silly one.
It's my birthday yesterday.
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Zest.
I went up an octave.
I have been singing for a lot today, you guys.
I had a three hour recording session.
For only one song!
And then the other thing that I was recording took like 30 minutes.
So I'm kind of tired.
My voice is a little tired too.
I don't think I've ever taken so long on just one song before.
But I wanted it to sound good.
I did many takes.
And also part of...
I didn't know it very well.
It's my birthday!
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Junii.
What's going on in March?
Lampy!
Oh, sorry.
Upside down Lampy.
Thanks for the gift.
Mintos spends three hours singing happy birthday.
I guess March is close enough to Valentine's Day, huh?
God, all these dang normies.
Celebrating Valentine's Day.
What's up with this?
Stop it.
Did you hear about the new Gundam series?
I saw.
But is this different from the new Gundam that they announced before?
Or is it...
SwizzleStick.
I like your profile picture.
Welcome to Lampy's show.
Damn Riaju.
But no, I actually...
It's funny because the idol I like...
I retweeted about the new Gundam.
She's really into Gundam.
And I...
I saw that it was there, but I didn't have time to watch it.
How do you say G...
Gquack?
Is that what it is?
Gquacks?
Miku's fries!
Welcome back for six months.
Thank you.
It's not my birthday, I'm just here to give you...
It will be soon.
Or it was your birthday.
Ashes.
I know.
It's written by Hide Akiyano.
G...
Gquacks.
But just look at the katakana, right?
I saw support on this day.
My birthday wish is for you to have all the wisps have a...
For you and all the wisps to have a nice day and night.
Penguin Crossing, happy birthday!
Why is it every time I start singing this song, the music picks up?
Happy birthday...
To you...
Happy birthday, Penguin Crossing!
Happy birthday...
To...
You...
The game is reading the room.
Which we will be doing.
We'll be reading the room.
I'm... I'm doing a yomi.
Wait.
I'm yomi-ing.
And by it, I mean...
The room.
Wait, why didn't I just say it?
I'm reading.
And by it...
Wait, I'm reading it.
And by it, I mean...
The room.
Guys, did you hear?
Did you hear?
Donna Burke.
I meant it's not my birthday.
It's not your birthday, Chaya.
But it was Woshingo's birthday yesterday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Woshingo.
How many is that now?
That's not even... We're barely... We're not even 15 minutes in.
We've already done like 5 birthday songs.
5.
Me when I'm reading it.
And by it, I mean the room.
The.
Wait, reading room, the.
Wait.
Me when I'm read... Wait.
Did you mean the right thing?
Considerate.
You guys, have you considered...
Not being so...
Stupid.
I'm just kidding.
No.
Let's consider something.
Let's consider... You guys... I'm not... Okay.
This is gonna sound kind of pathetic, maybe.
But when I was with... When Matara came...
And I saw her, like, interacting with my mom.
And I was like, I don't even get...
My mom was like telling her stories about my childhood and stuff.
I was like, I don't even talk like this with my mom.
I was like, is there something wrong?
I actually considered maybe that there's something wrong with me.
Because I have such a lack of social skills.
Do you know how many plushies ended up selling?
I don't know, actually.
I haven't checked.
But...
Plushies are on sale, baby!
Extroverts be like that?
Okay.
And I was like...
I was like, Matara would say something and she would be like, yeah.
You know...
I just... There was one conversation we were having.
She was like, it's obvious how you talk to people.
You just talk to them like this.
And I was like, I've never thought of it like that.
She was like, but why do you always know what to say on stream?
I thought that was calculated.
I was like, what are you talking about?
What am I... I know what to say on stream.
I don't know.
What do you mean?
Sometimes she would just be like...
She would be like, yeah, it's really obvious when you...
Like, just know what to say in these types of situations.
And I'm like, I don't... I've never considered that.
She kind of equated it to being like...
She was like, if you're a waitress, you know...
If you have a group of old ladies come to your restaurant and you're a waitress...
And they ask for wine and you have to be like...
Okay, ladies, let me see some ID.
Even though, you know, I was just like...
That's how you interact with people.
Like, I just...
Pathetic affection.
Happy birthday, Minky.
Thanks!
It's not my birthday.
But yeah, I don't know.
Maybe she can kukiyomi really well.
But me...
We have to learn.
So I hope this will help me become better at the kukiyomi.
It only takes 23 people to have a 50% chance of 2 or more people with the same...
Date of birth.
What?
That's...
That's so little!
The stream is totally not scripted.
What do you mean by that?
Kukiyomi.
Quick...
Considerate.
Quick kukiyomi.
Hey, Minky.
Long time chatter.
First time viewer.
Hope you're doing well.
Can you come to my house and check the insides of my walls for water damage?
I already went.
You're fine.
Two people kukiyomi.
Considerate together.
But we don't have two people, so...
Otanoshimi corner.
Fun minigames.
I hope you find the kukiyomi today.
It's delicious.
Very bad with reading Japan writing.
No, it's okay.
It's...
It...
You know, it's not easy.
It's not easy.
Let's do normal kukiyomi.
Bing bong.
This is a space where you are free to consider things as you like.
There is no one here to stop you from being as considerate as you please.
Or as inconsiderate.
Atara is a whole different social level.
It just made me feel like...
I don't know.
Maybe there is something wrong with me.
She can conversate so well, so easily.
I can't do that.
After considering the situation, move the red object on the screen.
Sometimes there may be nothing to move.
Just do what you consider the appropriate action.
If you wish to stop playing, just push the escape key.
Number one.
Mito, it's your birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Oh, I thought it was going to rush me.
Happy birthday, dear Relic.
Happy birthday to you.
Me, Pear Pear.
Do I also leave?
I considered it for the first time.
Number two.
Oh, I have to press it every time.
OK, what is this?
Sorry.
Wait.
Oh, I could have gone up.
OK, there you go.
I'm a little hare.
Pluck me.
Ow!
Oh, it worked.
I was dancing?
The game is rigged.
My stuff finally shipped.
I'm so excited.
Where are we going?
Me first!
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
To be fair, I was there first.
So...
To be fair...
I didn't know where the line was going to start.
OK?
I just thought...
Mint is mint and Mato is Mato.
You don't need to be any different.
Thank you.
So real, how do people just talk with no purpose?
They make things up on the spot?
I don't know.
All I know is to talk about leather.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Oh!
What if I need to go back down?
Just kidding.
This is where I wanted to go.
Probably.
Thanks for the two of us.
Do you like cookies too?
Do you like your yummy cookies?
Today is your birthday?
No, it's not.
Oh my...
It's not straight enough.
Come on.
So close.
OK.
That looks good.
We happily resonate with introvert Minky.
But wouldn't it be more exciting if I was not an introvert and I could be like...
Oh, today I talked to...
Today I talked to a grandpa.
And he said that he had five raccoons.
And I could tell you that story.
But since I don't talk to people, I can never tell you the story about the five raccoons.
We love you platonically the way you are.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh!
My results!
In some way or another...
Considerate.
I'm considerate!
If I wanted to watch a normie, I'd watch a normie.
OK.
I'm not.
I don't know how to be.
I'm considerate though.
Oh my gosh.
I'm becoming more normie than you realize.
I prefer the stories of these Donkey Kongs.
What's this?
Oh no!
Oh!
Now it looks like my peen is out.
OK.
Hold on.
Oh!
Sorry!
That was my face.
I'm picking my nose.
OK.
Nevermind.
Hold on.
This is fine.
It's for my own discomfort.
For the comfort of others.
I didn't mean to smack him.
I thought I was going to smack my own face.
OK.
Oh no, no, no.
Yeah!
This is...
Yes!
Oh sorry.
My head is kind of blocking it.
We got the full signal baby.
This is... Is that reading the room?
Read the WiFi.
Is that reading the room?
I'm a baby.
I'm a ba...
Oh.
Huh?
I was just staring at the baby.
I hate when babies stare at me though.
Quit staring.
Don't stare at me baby.
I don't care if I'm enriching you.
Oh, what is that?
Run away!
Oh, I think they're playing tag.
Eek!
Oh, I'm it.
Where did my other friend go?
Oh, we're playing tag!
Oh...
Huh?
Minto, that's a mirror.
Well shut up!
Row it!
Axen, thank you so much for the tag gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And you just joined membership too, didn't you?
Thank you so much!
It's time for the plushie and merch.
In the future there's going to be some quality mint themed casual wear.
I thought that said underwear.
Would you like mint themed underwear?
What kind?
Bandana underwear.
Maybe.
Yes?
What if it's really lacy?
They still care?
The hole in the back?
Oh my gosh.
They're not mine!
They're meant for you to wear.
What do you fear having the snickers with your bum out?
A hormonal phantomos or a certain sticky space bug?
P.S.
You smell.
Love you.
Shut up!
I don't think Matara will get it.
Oh my god, I'm kissing!
This is how you pretend how to...
This is where you learn how to French kiss everybody.
Stick your tongue in there!
Like that, you know?
That's how you learn.
In some way or another...
Considerate.
I'm considerate!
Rabbit is spooky.
Why is he giving me the middle finger?
Rude?
He's not considerate at all.
Number 11.
I wonder how many there are.
Lucky 11.
You like the faucet?
What?
No.
It's a water fountain.
In you go.
Oh no, I don't know this game.
Wait...
I did it!
I did it.
Number 13.
A friend brought their kid along.
Hey mister, what's this game?
Which one?
Bobo Taro Party!
Grab the Bobo Taro Party!
The other one was the Lion King probably.
You are in rare form tonight.
What do you mean by that?
What?
What if I just get the edge?
I was so close.
Try again.
Giant rice ball is coming right up.
Thanks for waiting.
On the table.
In the middle.
They mean you are cuter than normal.
I'm considerate.
Yeah!
In some way or another.
Why does she look like that?
Why is she so upset at him?
Why?
Hold on, let's join in on the judgment.
We are joining in.
Actually no, I think this is too judgy.
You can photoshop yourself on the other side.
And then it's like I'm judging you with all your little rice balls.
You know?
He took all the food.
What if she doesn't like rice balls?
What if he... Look, he's blushing.
He's like...
I'm...
The rice... What if he's giving them... What if he's proposing to her with them?
You're stinkier than usual.
I'm not stinky at all!
Moo, I'm a cow.
This is a cheese colored soup.
What's my favorite kind of cookie?
Today... This is not answering your question.
I'm sorry.
Today I really wanted a donut.
So I went to the donut place.
I went to Dunkin Donuts.
And I got a donut.
And I got some coffee.
Except they forgot my donut.
And so I said... I went back and I was like...
Please, you forgot my donut.
So they gave me two donuts!
Yummy!
I got two donuts.
Yeah, that's not a cookie.
My favorite cookie might be...
Okay, the ghost ones.
The Pillsbury ghost ones.
They released those seasonal sugar cookies.
I really like those.
And then also oatmeal cookies.
Oatmeal raisins.
Cookies.
Yeah.
Angel, thanks for the gift!
They forgot my donut.
And I got two donuts.
Number 16.
Why am I so... Oh, there we go.
Sorry.
Oh, wait.
Oh, now I'm normal.
Okay.
Oh
my gosh.
I was almost so in sync.
She gave us the fave donut.
Oh, give us the fave... Oh, Boston cream donut.
Or chocolate glazed donut, but I like Boston cream.
They say you don't have anecdotes in small talk.
It's finally my turn!
Wait.
Oh, please seat yourself where you like.
I'm gonna sit at the bar.
In the corner.
Boston cream is so good.
So good, right?
And then I also like the chocolate glazed.
Depends on what I'm into.
Or what I'm in the mood for.
Oh, my eyeball.
I'm looking.
We're fine.
We don't look upset.
Oh, we don't stare.
We don't stare.
We're fine.
Welcome to the zoo.
Wait, I wanna be the poop.
This rap is disgusting.
Stinky.
Let's see.
Today is the field trip.
Hey, you wanna trade lunches?
Oh, hey, you wanna trade lunches?
I'll trade you this for mine.
You can get a tomato.
What was he trading me?
Terra, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Was that Thriller?
No.
It's some way or another.
Considerate.
You guys, I'm killing it.
What is that?
It's not like a takoyaki.
It was a meatball.
Oh, I should've given one of my little octopuses, huh?
No, I should've given it my wiener.
Oh, I'm sorry.
The wiener taco.
Wake up, my sweet you.
Today is your... Don't say birthday.
Please, no more birthdays!
Retro511, welcome to membership.
Oh, it's your 18th birthday.
Say hello politely when you get to the castle.
Alright, off you go.
Happy birthday, Minky.
But it's my birthday.
How else would I learn about the world?
Am I wearing... I'm wearing pants, right?
It kind of looks like my butt's out.
Well, that's the perfect place to go then.
My butt's out.
Happy birthday to me, baby.
It's my treat, so pick whatever sounds good.
Parfait for two.
Well, that means I can shower.
It's a five-star surprise!
Thanks for the five characters!
I should probably get something kind of cheap though, right?
Like a chicken rice bowl.
But what if I'm allergic to chicken?
The grill is only a dollar more.
Well, we probably should get two.
Sorry sir, I guess I'm only eating for what you can share a plate.
Mint wiener!
Oh.
Wait, I... No, I pressed... I pressed it though.
I pressed it.
Uh-oh, maybe I got too close.
Oopsie.
My friend.
This is... There we go.
Oh.
Dear sir.
Wait, it's on this side, right?
It's on this side or this side?
Uh-oh, I don't know.
Oh, I have to wet the stamps?
Oopsie.
Oh no!
Man, I'm so hungry.
I know, right?
Is this Grave of the Fireflies?
Is that Anpanman?
If you're hungry, take a bite of my head.
I
like Baikinman more.
Immediate results.
Truly, mildly considerate.
Still considerate.
Another bite of 87.
She's hungry after two donuts.
I only had one donut.
Thank you.
Me now.
Single file.
You didn't even eat the one he gave you.
But also, it was Grave of the Fireflies.
It's an eat or be eaten world.
It's a dog-eat-dog world.
You have to be... You know, the Grave of the Fireflies, those kids died because they didn't have anything to eat, so they have to eat all...
Oh my gosh.
I just stay still.
Because they're painting me.
But what if I...
No brain.
Just kidding.
You thought.
What if I...
Just kidding.
I wouldn't do that to you.
You're painting.
Don't worry about it.
Who wants a squeeze of lemon?
Oh.
Sorry.
I thought everybody had their hands up.
What is going to happen?
I would eat that thing whole.
I didn't think that it would actually work.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Teach him a lesson.
Now then, which one of you broke the flower vase?
Keep your heads down, everyone.
Would the guilty party please honestly raise your hand?
Oh my god!
Oh, sorry.
Please put your hands down again.
You can all sit up again now.
I saw.
I saw everything.
I saw everything!
Oh my god.
School play!
Once upon a time in a far away land...
There lived an old man...
And an old woman...
And...
Oh, the old man went to...
The mountain for firewood.
And the old woman did...
The washing in the river.
What's next?
In some way or another...
Consider it.
Why would they do a play line by line like that?
Sounds horrible.
I did a play once.
I was supposed to be...
Or rather, it was a play.
And it was of Cinderella.
And the teacher who...
Who was giving the part said...
You, Mint, would be Cinderella.
You're perfect for the part.
I was like, yay!
But then...
But then, I did not get Cinderella.
I got the part of the Fairy Godmother.
Because...
The girl who got Cinderella...
This happens every year.
Or it happened every year.
Because the girl who got Cinderella...
Her mom...
Her mom always gave the school all of the tech equipment and lighting and sound and everything like that.
So...
So, she always got the main part.
Even as a kid, I would be like...
This isn't fair.
Yeah, bribed her way to being the main role for every play.
Every play every year, we had one.
It was so messed up.
I wanted to be Cinderella.
Now, I'll never be able to be Cinderella.
I'm stuck as a god damn Fairy Godmother.
No!
I don't want to be the Fairy Godmother.
I'm so angry.
I'm still angry.
Adventurer's Tavern.
That's when I learned that life is cruel.
Excuse me.
I'm looking for travel buddies.
Oh, travel buddies.
Lum!
I mean, I can't go wrong with a demon.
Life is cruel.
Afterlife is cruel.
You can never win.
You're Cinderella in my heart, Mito.
Cinderelly, Cinderelly.
Night and day, it's Cinderelly.
Do the dishes, and the washing, and the cooking, and the cleaning, and the dishes, and the washing.
Minky is Cinderella in our hearts.
Cut my hair, please.
What if I... I'm having a hard day.
I need someone to lean on.
Oh my goodness.
Never mind.
I think I'm possessed.
Hold on.
How far does it go?
Okay, just there.
Sorry.
I just needed somebody to lean on.
This isn't my stop.
It's not my stop.
Then I shouldn't get off.
Right?
Oh!
Okay, this is what you do in Japan when it's like this, right?
If it's really busy, you do this.
And then you stand here.
And you wait for people to get off.
And then you go back on.
That's what you do.
Don't worry, Mito.
You're still my princess.
I'm not the princess!
I'm the maid!
That's maybe why I could never be Cinderella.
Because I'm just always a maid.
But wait, Cinderella, it was a maid to her family.
But she got to be made into a princess.
I'll never be able to be made into a princess.
I'll always just be the maid.
It's cherry blossom season.
You can find us a spot, right?
Who's there?
Oh, okay.
Nobody's there, but you know.
I'll go to the very edge.
The tippy-tippy toe.
There we go.
Oh, you can't see.
See?
Look at that.
We're being considerate because we're not overstepping their thing.
But what if they want more company?
Oh, see?
Everybody gets to see.
Perfect.
Queen never cry.
Our subway stop is always crowded and nobody moves to let you out.
You have to fight your way out.
No!
It's so annoying.
Whisper never cry.
That's not true.
Very vaguely considerate.
But still, considerate.
Number 36.
I sounded like Spongebob.
I sounded like Spongebob laugh.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, gorsh.
Properly wearing your mask.
Considerate.
Number 37.
Taking a relative's kid out to eat.
Spinning sushi!
Considerate.
Number 38.
I go to the spinning sushi for me.
Oh...
I'm getting high.
Considerate.
I don't pass out in there.
I'm considerate.
Number 39.
Thank you!
Did I just...
Did I just lose them?
Oh my god!
He took my pants!
Considerate.
Hits the guy next to me, so he...
will give them back.
Number 40.
I hope he doesn't see the little hole in the back.
And now, a word from the principal.
Good morning, everyone!
The weather's been warming up lately, and it's really starting to feel like the summer.
That summer sun is scorching, huh?
Make sure you don't get too much sun...
Candy store on the way home.
They wanted it to be fast, so that they could go on a summer vacation.
Six months!
Truly mildly...
considerate.
I like the turtle.
Is that good?
What's the best considerate you could get?
Flowing noodles party!
Beat the summer heat!
Flowing noodles!
We can eat as much as we want!
How do I do this?
Oh no!
OK, it needs to go at a moderate speed.
You'll eat children!
Oh my gosh.
Why is it so hard being a noodle?
There we go.
Eat it!
Grab it!
Mike, thanks for six months too!
Me too, I'm so considerate.
I am.
Aren't I?
What is this?
Oh!
Wow!
Sweaty.
You're doing great, sweaty.
Forty-three.
Shhh...
Oh!
That's the perfect temperature.
I'm the most considerate egg ever!
Oh my gosh!
Mince my sweaty.
Says who?
Jesse!
Make the girl sweaty.
Oh!
January hot.
February hot.
March is still cold.
Hot.
All hail Stinky Minky.
OK.
Now...
Cold.
Have cold.
OK.
Cold.
Yeah.
I like how in Japan you can get the hot drinks in the winter time and the cold drinks in the summer time.
So good.
I want hot coffee year round.
Oh, maybe I should have left one.
But that's like electricity.
You're not being very considerate.
You know that?
If you ask for all cold and one hot, you know how much more electricity that's using than just keeping them all cold or all hot?
You're not being very considerate.
Think of the environment.
Gosh!
SOS!
Foreigner!
I should have taken a picture.
In some way or another...
Considerate.
Look at the turtles.
They're so cute.
Wouldn't heating be way less energy?
Yes, but only one?
You'll be mine.
Welcome to membership.
The rabbit.
Today is our date on a cruise?
Since we're here, why don't we go do that thing?
Oh,
I have to hug her.
Press A.
Oh, sorry.
Press B to hug.
Yeah, baby.
I love doing that.
Press B to hug.
What am I doing?
Oh, no!
Wait!
This is gonna be my thumbnail.
Oh my gosh.
I gotta get out of the way and tie my shoes.
What have I got back?
Okay, now I'm taking my spot again.
Oh, sorry.
I was walking in front of you before.
So, honestly, I deserve to take my spot again in front of you.
What if we're going to the famous pastry place and I was in front of them.
I had to tie my shoe, but I was in front of them the whole time.
And we get to there and they're sold out.
He would've taken my spot.
I would've never gotten it.
His birthright.
His spot.
The last bread.
Yeah, exactly.
Grow big.
Grow big little saplings.
Let's pull our money and buy candy at the store to share.
Something to share.
Baseball and chips?
Oh my boy.
So funny.
Let's get some donuts.
I got donuts today.
I will get donuts.
Oh, play 50 questions and consider it.
I'm half way there.
Some way or another.
Consider it.
Bakemon.
Wait, what is Obabake?
What is Obabake?
That's not me though.
Wake up my darling.
You?
Oh no.
Don't say it.
It's not my birthday is it?
Please don't say birthday.
Don't say birthday.
Today is your 30th birthday!
You get your first subordinate.
What?
Go to the castle and mentor the next generation.
Alright, off you go.
A sub...
Go to mentor time!
In the end, I chose my own path.
What should I have for lunch today?
Oh, hello sir.
Would you mind if I ate lunch with you?
Sure.
Come here.
I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a you of few words.
Take as much as you want.
I'll be honest, I don't really like the pig bowl.
That's how much as I want.
What do I do with the rest?
What do I... actually I...
Oh no, that's mine.
I don't want so much of it.
Grab the whole bowl.
I don't want it though.
I don't like it.
I don't like the taste.
Oh!
Oh, it was full.
lol
Sorry, I was that person.
The bus.
Oh man!
Why is the... Wait!
Oh no!
Oh, it's a schoolgirl.
We stopped the bus for her.
You're welcome!
You're welcome.
You're welcome, schoolgirl.
Do do do do.
In some way or another...
Consider it.
Umai.
Umai bowl.
It is a joke about umai bowl.
Which are these.
I don't know what they are made out of.
They are just like these...
Maybe like corn.
Corn sticks.
And they taste good and they are really fluffy.
When you eat them, they're There you... you... you eat it.
Yeah, it's like a Cheeto.
Yes, yes, yes.
Like a big Cheeto.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it's like a tube Cheeto.
And it's just...
It's so delicious.
Cheeto puff.
Oh, dada.
What a good kid you are.
If only things could stay like this forever.
I made them...
The stranger moved next door.
What was that?
That was like Puyo, but creepy.
I'm new here.
Can't believe how inconsiderate the streamer is.
No!
It's his bald head.
It's reflecting.
Work!
Keep working!
But don't you like the sunlight?
Can I let you know that you're not working out, you know?
What else do I do?
OK.
Solar flare!
Yeah, I want the natural light.
I can't believe... I can't believe Godzilla can now like...
Do Fortnite dances.
I can't believe Godzilla can hit the gritty.
I can't believe this.
I just...
Also, I heard... Tell me if this is true or not.
But I heard that Godzilla is in Fortnite, but they couldn't get the license for his roar.
So what does he sound like then?
If he can't do his...
I think that was a pretty good impression, actually.
That's what he sounds like.
He just sounds like a normal dude.
He's like...
His roar is just an elbow scream.
Do Fortnite stream win?
Maybe I'll play with Doki.
I have Snake and... Well, I didn't get Raiden.
Squire!
Welcome to membership!
I like your profile picture.
Minky.
That's me.
Oh no!
Right on the kisser.
Alright, now kiss it to make it feel better.
Does it feel better?
I can't believe... Oh wait, hold on.
What is this?
There you go.
Oh, you got a lot of rice there.
He's touching his thumb a little bit.
Okay, I need to ask this too.
When you eat curry, do you like your curry and your rice separate?
Not like separate bowls or anything, but like...
When I pour rice and curry, I put my rice on one side and my curry on the other side.
You don't like curry?
No!
There's different kinds of curry.
Side by side.
Yeah, I like it side by side too.
I prefer it mixed, but then you don't have the flavor of the rice.
The curry overpowers it.
Never had curry.
If you don't like curry, this is my recipe.
You get the mild mix of the golden curry.
And you put in the potatoes, and you put in the carrots, and you put in the onion.
And then you put in the applesauce.
Yeah, then you put in the applesauce.
And it helps thicken it up and also gives a sweet, sweet apple taste.
Oh, and the chicken.
The chicken too.
It's so yummy.
I promise.
Let's see.
Very vaguely considerate.
Why?
That's not a lot of considerate though, right?
I thought I was pretty considerate this time.
Skims.
Today is our date at a cafe.
What am I doing?
I have to have some drink.
I'm not trying to finish it.
I'm just trying to... I'm literally only having sips.
I
need a backwash.
What do you know?
I was only trying to drink half.
But if I only drink half, then I wouldn't have... It reached my mouth.
Just a little bit.
OK, but you guys say ew, but if you had the chance to drink an anime girl's backwash, I know you would.
OK?
Don't act like you are better than me.
Don't act like you are holier than thou now, OK?
You would be like, you guys are just like...
Sweaty girl.
But you draw the line at backwash?
OK.
I don't want to hear it from you all.
Coco curry level 10 spice with cheese and pork.
Cutlet.
Side by side with Thai tea.
If it was mint, 110% yes.
Nasty.
Can't hold it in any longer.
Restroom.
This way.
Wait, I think I made it too big and he thought that was the restroom.
Oopsie.
Lily boys.
Please.
May have more condemnable ship.
Thank you!
Good heavens, the bamboo is glowing.
Is something inside?
Oh my gosh, we have to not...
Oh, wait, don't kill the baby.
We were expecting some kind of...
Wow!
Mockback.
What do you mean by that?
David Seal, thank you for the 50th gift!
Thank you!
I'm thinking.
Mighty Wobb, welcome to Bubble Ship.
Thank you.
I want that spit on...
Bring it on you monster!
I didn't know what to do!
I think I was supposed to stand in front of him, right?
Very vaguely considerate.
Why is the screen giving Exit 8 vibes?
Nothing to see here, folks.
So, do you want us to be freaky about you or not?
Your answer will change my behavior.
Well, see, be true to yourself.
Be true to yourself.
Blink!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Take this, you monster!
Did it work?
So
be freaky?
Yeah, be freaky if you must be freaky.
I can handle the freak.
But don't, you know, not everybody can handle the freak.
But I can handle your freak.
Most considerate ghost mid.
I am the freak martyr.
I will absorb the freak so no others have to deal with the freak.
I understand.
It's okay.
I can take it.
I will take it.
Then no others will have to deal with this freak.
Me!
What am I doing?
Wait.
I'm moonwalking.
Visiting a business partner.
They are expecting us at 3 o'clock.
Got it.
Considerate.
Oh I got an achievement right on target.
Number 69 The class change seats.
Why do I
have such a big head?
Nice.
I have such a big head.
Backup nerd.
Wait.
No, no, no.
I'm trying not to...
Did you get this part?
You got this part now?
OK.
Oh this is good.
Sayonara!
Alright.
Nice.
Very vaguely considerate.
What do you mean?
But I was so considerate.
I was so considerate.
I should say that I'm the most considerate.
71 I'm scared.
If you rescue a crane, a beautiful lady appears.
But my grandma punched a crane.
I'll weave some cloth for you.
Please don't look in here until I say it's alright.
What a dork.
He's so easy to fool.
Now I'll just do this and this.
Alright.
It turned out great.
Wait.
What do you mean?
I wove the very finest of cloth.
The cloth ought to please even that man.
She never said look.
Am I easy?
Yeah, I think so.
Pretty lady.
When the last leaf falls, my time will come.
No, no, no.
Oh no.
She even had the dead mom hair.
Oh my gosh.
What was I seeing?
Something.
For some reason, this thought made me think of it.
There's some anime.
I think it's like...
Not the heroine anime.
Oh gosh.
I saw a tweet about it the other day.
Where...
It might have showed up on your timelines too.
But someone was just like, I'm so mad.
Because...
This anime is so bad.
The guy... The girl...
Goes into a coma and then gets out.
It's a recent anime.
And then...
And then he goes with the other girl.
Because his girlfriend is in the...
In the hospital.
And...
He's like, welcome to membership.
No, not erased.
Oh, I think it was domestic girlfriend.
Yeah, I think it was domestic girlfriend.
I saw someone being upset about it.
They were just like, oh, this happened.
But they described exactly everything that happens in Kimi no Zou.
I was just like...
No way.
First time?
Is this like... Is domestic girlfriend...
Kimi no Zou for Gen Z?
I was like, no way.
I can't believe this is happening again.
It was so funny.
I saw it.
I wanted to comment and be like, oh no.
You should watch Kimi no Zou.
Oh, what's happening?
Two?
Wait.
What's going on?
Oh, I sneezed.
Under the table dweller.
What does that mean?
Time is a flat circle.
So true.
No, stay away thoughts.
Stay away thoughts.
Yeah, baby.
I'm doing my horny meditation.
It's horny meditative hours everybody.
Me on the daily.
Bless you.
Thank you.
Bakemon card!
Rare card.
We're
gonna do it... We're gonna give it to the kid.
You just stirred an old memory with Kimi no Zou.
Give it to the kid.
The others are scalpers.
Rare card for you buddy.
Rare card for you.
Moderately considerate.
Look at this bird.
What?
I don't want to tell you how to do your job.
But you might want to keep anime girl backwash in your back pocket in case you get a game yourself.
Nosey.
Nosey, no.
Shut up.
Eww.
Nobody will...
What
would the flavor be?
Lemon?
Lemon.
Gross.
Oh, they're doing a TikTok.
Wait, but this actually helps it go viral.
If the cat sits in it, it goes viral.
It goes viral.
People like the cat, you know.
They're like wow, that's so funny.
The cat got in the video.
It's better.
It's better for the TikTok.
This is me!
This is MissY, your favorite VTuber signing off.
Until next time!
Hot mic.
Oh hey Mr. Producer, nice work today.
Our reviews are looking great.
I totally told you.
Wait, I totally owe you.
Oh right, that surprise thing we're planning.
Our listeners are going to go nuts for it.
I mean come on!
Oh wait, we're gonna... I didn't see anything.
Can't wait for combined anime girl thighs and anime girl back ones.
Stop!
I didn't see it!
Did you guys see it?
Look brother, fireflies!
So pretty.
Wait, sorry.
I expected her to say she hates her viewers.
She can't have my thing.
Listen, can you wake me up in a little bit?
Little bit.
Was that enough you think?
OK, now it's even.
OK, now it's an even fight.
Oh my gosh, they're doing so well.
Very vaguely considerate.
I like how that one was just Doki's neck.
You see your co-worker on a day off.
Oh he's with his girlfriend!
No...no conversation.
We're all signing this keepsake card.
Oh, it went so fast.
Thank you.
Love.
Wait, I didn't mean to draw that.
OK, hold on.
What do I get for that?
Thanks for the peach.
OK.
What was I supposed to do?
Oh, sign in the card.
Sign in the card.
Nothing to see.
Dramatic posing!
That was good.
That was so clean.
Hi there!
I'm the server robot.
If you need service, leave it to me!
Oh my gosh, I miss Caitlyn.
Darn humans forcing me to work for pennies.
Look over here, so cute!
Hehe.
Clumsy girl!
That made me miss Caitlyn.
I've been watching a playthrough of Final Fantasy VII Rebirth.
I'm like... I don't know exactly.
I think I'm close to the end.
I don't know if it's the last chapter or not.
But I love... I call him Caitlyn.
I'm obsessed with Cait Sith.
I love him.
I love Caitlyn so much.
I think he's... Oh my gosh, I can't stop thinking about him.
He's so cute!
And that does remind me of Caitlyn!
So cute!
I can't stop thinking about him because he's so
handsome and has two bright teeth.
My
god, I love him so much.
Merch up him at the Square Enix cafe.
I'm gonna buy... Hold on, I need a tissue.
I'm gonna buy all his stuff.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, I just moved my contact down my eye.
Oh my god!
I can't think about him without crying.
Oh, he's so cute.
Oh gosh.
And then...
And then he... Last night I saw him...
Basically...
Basically every day after stream I've been watching a little bit more.
It's like my treat for after stream, right?
And I...
I... So...
I... It makes it... I...
Hold on, I'm getting confused.
Wait.
I wanted to play it, but I just didn't have time.
And I...
So I was like, I'll just watch someone, but it makes me wanna play it now.
It makes me wanna play it, but I was just like, I can't stream this.
Because I just... I have so many other things to stream.
And if I were... I feel like if I were to be like, hey guys, I'm adding Final Fantasy VII to my playlist...
People would be like, but what about all these other RPGs you talked about?
So...
I've never played the OG Final Fantasy VII either.
I know the story, I know about it.
But, I've never played the original.
Please play Final Fantasy VII.
I'm begging on my knees to play it, please.
But I'm watching it.
Right now...
I... I haven't finished it.
Probably will finish it tonight.
And then...
Because I want to...
I want to...
Then...
The third one.
Three really long games.
I know, I know.
FFXIV has Old Man Yaoi?
Wait, what?
Really?
Wait, wait.
It does?
Wait.
Final Fantasy X.
I've played Final Fantasy X.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Should play FFXIV.
That's not...
But FFXIV is the MMO, right?
FFXIV is the MMO though, right?
I don't have time for that.
But the Old Man Yaoi?
Really?
It's got the... It's got the goods.
It's got the good stuff.
It's got the... It's got the good stuff.
I enjoyed Remake and I'm patiently waiting for Rebirth to come on Steam.
Please hurry Square Enix.
Yeah.
I like Rebirth so far.
I mean, I'm almost to the end.
I think because...
Because he's...
Because Galen is so cute.
They couldn't have made a more perfect character.
No.
I love Caitlyn.
Sorry, I really love that guy.
Except when he turns into an old man.
I don't love that.
I just like the cat.
Okay.
No, let's keep playing the game.
My sons, look closely.
Alone this arrow is weak and fragile.
Oh my god!
See how easily it breaks.
Even when two arrows put together.
Am I supposed to be doing something?
See?
The same outcome.
But then three arrows, like the three of you are put together.
I don't know which way I'm supposed to put my thing at.
It's strong.
No, no, no, no.
There we go.
I don't know which way I'm supposed to do this.
I'm sick so I can't smell anything.
It's a perfect time to watch stream.
But you'll miss the smell-o-vision, Eggman.
13 is long, but it has old man yaoi.
And they just released a new hardest fight.
That's just Yuri.
Very vaguely...
When it's supposed to be the three of them, it was supposed to not break, right?
How am I vaguely considerate?
Is it because I'm taking too long on the game?
Oh no!
OK, we're fine now.
Hey co-worker.
Hey new guy.
Nice, I was considerate.
Considerate!
OK, 87.
How will you pay?
With my phone.
Oh, sorry.
There we go, sorry.
There we go.
One kid's video with a toy...
Wait, it's a VTuber!
I'll put it in the middle.
You guys can share.
Hey, let me ask you something.
Which teacher is your favorite?
Let me see...
The sexy one.
Kind Mr. A or cool Mr. B?
Oh, regular old Mr. C!
Kind Mr. A.
No...
Finding out that Kamiyoshi is a huge fan of the same character?
OK, then.
See, my lord.
Oh, sorry.
Very vaguely considerate.
Why?
Mr. C needed a win today.
Mr. C needs to give less homework then.
OK?
Mr. C then needs to not yell at me in class.
Mr. C is kind of a jerk.
It's a plappy meal.
What do you mean it's a plappy meal?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, I like to get the veggie.
I'll get one of each.
Thank you.
Delicious.
See you again soon.
Let's go out for BBQ next time.
Oh, bye-bye!
Yummy.
Wait, not yummy.
Sorry.
I was thinking of hot pot still.
I think I'm hungry.
It didn't wave.
It didn't let me.
It didn't let me wave.
You have to push a button.
I did!
I tried!
Let's watch the first sunrise of the new year.
Oh, the sun appears here.
The sun appears here.
We all saw it.
See, I didn't want the sun to shine in her eyes.
My girlfriend's eyes.
What's that?
There's something rustling in there.
What's going on in there, kids?
It's a cat.
Knock it off, kids.
What's that guy doing here?
Uh...
I'm confused.
I'm truly mildly concerned.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I didn't know what the heck was going on there.
Apologizing to a business partner.
These things happen the best to the best of us.
We'll bring them some cake, eh?
Okay.
Sorry, cake.
Candles too, please.
I see a ghost.
A ghostly maid.
That's me.
Thanks for four months, Toon.
Special delivery.
Wait, power?
Power?
Wait, what?
What's...
Shutting the door.
I shouldn't have slammed it.
Today we're making time capsules.
Please include a letter to your future self and something precious you want to give them.
Precious.
Precious kobabaki.
And my baseball.
And the note.
And this funny rabbit.
For a scare.
Super Liminal!
Thanks for the 10 gifts.
Thank you so much!
Oh, the note was that?
The note?
Oh my goodness.
Hi Minky.
First super chat for you and today is my birthday!
Sigma Tom, happy birthday!
Can I get a Diamond Dog birthday song?
Of course!
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Sigma Tom, happy birthday!
Yay!
I love when sometimes people request the Metal Gear version.
So fun.
Glad I can sing that for you guys.
Time capsule!
Second grade class me!
Dear me, hello.
After growing up, did I become an awesome hero?
Oh, I'm controlling the credits.
Right now I want to be a pilot or maybe a police officer.
It's so hard to decide.
I think it must be really cool to be all grown up and doing whatever you want.
I put some really special stuff in here.
Take good care of it please.
Dear past me, hello.
Do I do it again?
I'm sorry.
I didn't become a pilot or a police officer.
I haven't really accomplished my other dreams either.
I'm just living my life and trying to be considerate.
I mean, being considerate might not sound all that important but...
thinking of others can make the world a slightly nicer place.
That's why even though I grew up like this, part of me still thinks...
maybe I am being a hero.
Yeah, maybe I am.
Haha, that's so corny.
I'm probably just making excuses.
But if you ever want, I'd love to talk about the good old days again.
Well, goodnight.
Number one hundred.
Thank you for covering for me at work today.
You seriously saved my bacon.
You're totally my hero.
You're welcome.
I received words of gratitude.
In some way or another, considerate.
I'm scared.
You guys, I can't look.
I can't look.
I didn't even...
I didn't even make it half way.
Role comprehension is kind of good.
Empathy.
We all need more empathy.
Insight.
Timing is a little...
Thoroughly considerate.
A quick thinking bodyguard.
I'm thoroughly considerate though, you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm a quick thinking bodyguard.
I'm a bodyguard.
Know how.
Wait, what's the detail?
Oh.
Considerate fours ranking.
Common sense is disappointing.
Commonly understood social manners and etiquette.
This is the first step in becoming more considerate.
Specialized know how that isn't commonly known.
Having a lot of knowledge is an essential weapon for being more considerate.
Average.
Spatial awareness.
Sharpness for sense of direction and maintaining the right amount of distance.
Knowing your place helps in being considerate of others.
Very vaguely considerate.
Group dynamics is good.
The knowledge to understand the role of others expect you to play in a group.
Your cooperative nature leads to smooth teamwork.
I'm a team player, baby!
Zeonia, thanks for the 7 bucks.
What do ghosts make for good bodyguards?
Yeah.
Sympathy.
Above average!
See?
Whether or not you can put yourself in other's shoes and understand how they feel.
I'm very empathetic everybody.
I'm very empathetic.
I'm empathetic.
I was thinking about this earlier.
I feel that in a lot of cases, the world needs more empathy, more passion, more empathy.
I was just kind of thinking earlier about how there's been a lot of sad news and stuff with Vtubers and everything.
I was just thinking about how a lot of Vtuber fans are quite empathetic, I think.
I think it's actually quite nice.
Even if it's not your Oshi that's graduating, a lot of people will still be like, Don't worry, buddy.
I'm here for you.
I know it's your Oshi graduating.
Stuff like that.
It's actually quite nice that a lot of people will kind of come together.
And be like, Don't worry, I'm here for you.
Others are here for you.
It's kind of nice.
I was thinking about that earlier.
Adulting.
Above average.
Ability to step back and take in a situation then assume the roles others don't want to do, allowing everyone to better enjoy themselves.
My information integration is average.
The power to instantly find the right meaning from fragmented hints with no context.
But sometimes these are a little wild.
How am I supposed to know what to do with the animals?
Speed.
Average.
The ability to immediately make decisions in any situation.
The speed to understand and react to a situation.
Timing.
Poor.
My rhythm is poor.
No, but I...
Talent to following rhythm as instructed.
Being flexible with the ability to go with the flow will be useful in being considerate.
Interval.
Average.
Good and bad intervals.
Why is it that my rhythm is at 29?
Whether or not you understand the best timing when acting in a series of events.
I... I think I'm good.
Yeah!
Secrets?
The past you...
Oh my gosh, the VTuber.
Oh, this is when, like, you get... Like, that was my stop and...
Like, when I got this little kind of secret achievements.
Wow, there's one for each thing?
I only got six.
Holy moly.
Clumsy girl.
Candles too, please.
Wait, what was this one?
I don't remember getting this one.
Let's see, what are some of the minigames?
You game.
Eight yous.
Eight you game.
Start.
Is this a Suica game?
Oh no.
I think this is a Suica game.
Oh, did you see that?
Yeah, that one's tiny.
No way!
Oh my god.
And then it's gonna become a big...
Oh my god, no.
We had a Suica game!
Maybe I can knock this guy over.
Oh, oh, whoopsie.
I didn't mean to do that.
Tiny guy.
Big guy.
Wow, there's a lot of them.
Mildly considerate guy.
No, why are you stuck there?
That's not very considerate of you.
Yes.
So unsettling without colors.
It's honestly kind of hard to follow.
I'm gonna do this one.
Actually, I guess it doesn't really matter, but...
We'll do this guy and then they'll combine.
I've never played Suica game, you guys.
Should I play Suica game?
Does anybody still play Suica game?
I'll bring back Suica game.
I'll bring it back.
Wait, see?
These look like the same.
But they're not.
One is just more uncomfortable than the other.
Oh no.
Oh no, no, no, no!
Will it match?
He's gonna roll over and then into the big...
He's a square!
How am I supposed to move that?
No way.
Does he still move?
Okay, he moves, he moves, he moves.
Oh my gosh.
He's just a square.
Be there or be square, literally.
Guys, do you think I'm considerate?
Maybe this game...
You know, maybe I do have issues.
Like I thought.
Maybe I'm antisocial.
Oh no!
Oh god!
Oh no, I messed up.
Hit it!
Tada!
Oh no.
Just a little freaky.
I'm a degenerate?
Yeah.
But that's like...
Different than being considerate.
That's being a degenerate.
Oh no!
No!
The Blaze!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Will that hit?
Nice.
Touch me!
I wanna be dirty!
No!
Quarter of an hour.
Yeah.
You guys know that song?
Right?
Touch!
No!
Sorry.
Oh my god!
How many sizes is that?
Octagon looking.
Nine.
I think I'm done with this game.
I kinda wanna get the happy...
Let's just keep going until I die.
I'm just gonna play some...
Okay, this is the strat.
You just place things down...
And they eventually connect.
You know what I mean?
And then you eventually get something.
And then you win the game.
Let's see.
Spam the U's!
We'll get something eventually.
Maybe.
Oh no, it's not looking so good you guys.
I don't know.
Touch!
Sorry, it's been a long day for me.
Busy busy.
Working on some cool stuff for you guys.
Cool stuff!
Oh they're gonna touch!
They're gonna touch!
Oh my god, wait.
Maybe I can get them to touch.
Touch!
Hey friends!
Nakama!
Nakama you!
Oh no, I don't think I can get any closer.
Maybe this one.
Down!
It's so over.
I can't tell what's going on.
Cause every time we touch I get this feeling.
Every time I...
Every time I sleep?
Wait.
Cause every time we touch I get this feeling.
And every time we...
Sleep?
What's the next part?
I swear I can fly.
I think you answered this before but...
What's a clarifier?
Are we able to give small gifts at Phantom Thief?
I wanted to maybe give you a cheque from my event everyone.
Ah!
But let me ask first if we have a place for gifts.
I'll have to ask.
I think it should be fine.
And then also if Doki is okay with gifts too.
I think the website says no.
I'll double check.
The website says no.
Then no, I'm sorry.
Wait!
That's a different word!
I'll double check.
I'll just shoot a message right now.
I ask.
I ask, I ask, I ask.
Hello Mint.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Did it mean for you to pause the stream?
But it's important!
Okay, yeah.
I just got an answer.
We are not... Oh, wait.
We are not accepting gifts.
Unless you want us to.
Oh, wait.
It's also up to Doki too though, you know?
Two weeks ago I watched zero Vtubers.
Now I watch one.
And have 96 out of 97 achievements in Holocure.
Wait.
Which one do you watch?
Who's the one?
Fine, don't blame me.
I've been super tired.
How did you get so many achievements in such a short amount of time?
But I haven't even got that many.
Oh my gosh.
No, it might not be me though.
It could be someone in Hololive.
Because they play Holocure.
It's Doki.
See?
It's not even me.
You guys all get...
You guys get...
Oh my gosh!
No!
I thought I was about to die!
This sleepy man!
Get out of here!
Poison him in his sleep!
Then I'll have to leave.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
They said that!
It might be difficult for people bringing gifts...
through like security or whatever.
Minto not a VTuber?
I never said that!
I'm VTuber!
Oh!
I think today is the last day to vote for Lady VTuber.
If you...
Oh!
We got a regular guy!
Oh my god!
He's so regular!
Yeah!
Taking time to message Vanity on the spot to answer a fan's question.
Truly the most considerate ghostman.
Also hi!
This is my first ever Super Chat to you!
Das!
Thank you!
Thanks for the Super Chat!
Just a regular old guy.
A regular Joe.
He takes his coffee with one cream and one sugar.
Most average guy.
I'll vote for you anyway.
Good luck!
Thanks!
Yeah, if you want to see me maybe as a Lady VTuber...
in the VTuber Awards...
I was nominated...
alongside some other great VTubers.
Like Kiara Takanashi!
Lady VTuber.
You voted for me?
Thank you!
Are you a Lady VTuber?
I'm a lady, yeah.
I'm a little lady.
You could say that.
You could say I'm a little lady.
Guys, I don't know if we're going to get to the happiest guy.
I don't know if we're ever going to get to the happiest guy, but we got to regular guy.
Honestly, I feel like that's a win.
Oh my gosh, these look so similar!
Tiny lady.
I'll vote it for you.
Scan the gifts.
Thank you!
I don't think we'll...
I don't know if we'll be doing the gifts though.
I don't know.
But whenever I get gifts I always check them.
I do check.
Oh no!
Wait, what happens if I go outside?
Wait, can I combine with like this?
What if?
No!
I feel like this is the type of...
Oh, because it's like Suika game, but it's U game.
That's so funny.
I feel like this would be the type of game to troll you with that, you know?
What is this one?
Eight U's.
What is going on here?
Oh no!
It's Exit 8, but it's Ohmaiwa 8!
Look closely at all 8 U's.
If all 8 are the same, go forward.
If one is different, criticize them.
Pass through 8 cars to get out.
This is so fun!
I even mentioned Exit 8 earlier.
Oh!
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
It's not...
Okay, smartphones, smartphones, smartphones...
We go back.
Oh wait, we have to criticize them.
Now I remember that Minto's common sense score was low.
What are you talking about?
Oh, smack!
That's right.
Car 2.
We criticize them.
I didn't think criticizing was going to be so violent.
Hey!
Criticize!
Oh my god, the rapids in the back.
This is kind of scary.
They all look the same.
I think we're good.
Car 4.
Fallen... Oh!
Criticize!
Car 5.
No ass, no ass, no ass, no ass, no ass, no ass...
They all have the same face.
They're all holding with the same hand.
Next car.
They might crit his eyes when you bonk him.
Car 7.
He was like, he was expecting to get his ass slapped.
He was just like...
Wait a second.
Wait, how do I know?
Is it this guy?
Because this one is holding on to the first handle and this guy is holding on to the third hand.
What if I go?
Wow, cleared 8 U's and fun mini-games.
Hey Minto, are we able to leave gifts for you at the...
Kira, go.
Get out of here.
Go away!
Jump U.
No, no, wait.
This is just Jump King.
Oh my god, as soon as it said Jump U, I was like, wait, wait.
I think I know this.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Why does every game have to have a Jump King now?
Why does everything have to have a Jump King now?
Why every game?
This one is even worse because it's so slow.
Are those supposed to be crickets?
Oh my god, it's so slow.
Yeah, it's painfully slow.
I feel like I'm jumping in zero G's.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Okay, I can't do this, no.
Get me out.
Get me meowt.
Get me out of the game, please.
How do I stop the game?
Yes, stop playing the game.
Get me meowt.
If I say consider it together...
Oh, never mind.
I don't have a player 2.
Quick consider it.
Let's try this.
Wait, wait.
Hold on.
Go back, go back.
Okay, wait.
We can do the quick one and then I want to do the inconsiderate.
As a test run, we'll measure your consideration skills with 10 questions.
They're all rather easy.
This is a space where you are free to consider things as you like.
There is no one here to stop you from being as considerate as you please.
After considering the situation, move the red object.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Number 1.
This is quick mode guys.
Quick mode.
Oh.
I can't move.
You're welcome.
Okay.
We did this one before though.
Number 2.
Oh, we did this one too.
Let's leave.
These are the ones we've done before.
Inconsiderate mode.
You're welcome.
This is a space where you can freely mess around.
No one is going to hold you back.
Go ahead and mess around to your heart's content.
Please be inconsiderate and mess around.
There is no explanation.
Just go nuts.
Let's watch the first sunrise of the new year.
The sun rose.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah little pear.
Oh you're two peas in a pod.
You're a little pear pear.
How do they like that?
You think they like that?
Why is my Oshi such a freak?
This is inconsiderate mode!
Let me
in.
Please let me in, please.
I just stepped out for a second.
Number 4.
It's finally my turn.
It says sit wherever I... Actually I want to sit next to the pretty lady.
Maybe I should have gone to the toilet.
Just like in school.
Into the cup.
Put it in my drink.
Nasty.
Bacon?
No, I think it's like pickled ginger.
Moderately...bulk.
Bokeh?
Like...Bokeh?
It's cherry blossom season.
What if I went all the way though?
I'm going!
Bokeh is kind of like an airhead, I guess.
That's what the achievement I just got was.
Bokeh.
I'm a little stupid.
A little airhead-ish.
Number 8.
I'll go to number 10.
Excuse me.
Gosh.
Sorry.
It must be fate that we have collided into each other.
We collided into each other.
Oh, you dropped your wallet.
I'm not stealing it.
I'm picking it up for you.
Oh, pretty fair maiden.
It must be fate that we have collided today like this.
It's fate that we have met under these circumstances.
Isn't this just like your favorite rom-com?
Rom-com!
You reach down and you try to grab their wallet...
but you aren't stealing it, but you're trying to grab it to give it back to them, and then...
your hands touch.
Oh my god.
How embarrassing for you.
This is so embarrassing for you.
Oh my god.
This is horrible.
This is the worst thing that could actually happen to you.
Sorry, that was mean.
Embarrassing, embarrassing, embarrassing.
Gliding 3 times could be a coincidence, but 16 times?
That's fate.
It's true.
My treat, so pick whatever looks good.
I'm eating for 21.
Blackjack!
Middle-aged charmer.
Huh?
In some way or another.
Bokeh.
Fuck, look at all these guys.
Okay, how do I get out?
Game, let me be free.
Stop playing.
This is so silly.
I like Kukiyomi.
Even though I don't think I can always...
Sometimes I can't read it.
It's very unique.
It's fun because also it's just so...
Some of these things are just so Japanese.
You know?
I don't know how to tell you this, but...
Burger was just onigiri that's messier to eat.
What?
No!
Onigiri has...
Onigiri has nori.
This is not nori.
Phantom Sha!
Welcome to my voice chat.
Thank you!
I'm gonna head over to...
Give me a second.
We're gonna head over to my maid cafe.
It's been a minute.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
We're good, I think.
I think?
I think.
Sorry.
Some things have been kind of kooky on my computer.
My computer has been a little wackadoodle lately.
Yeah!
One second, let's put on some...
Some music.
Some ongaku.
I'll treat you to music until we get...
La la la la la la la la la la.
Misato!
Thanks for the tag after!
Thank you!
We'll do this one, it's been a minute.
Yeah.
We were considerate today, everybody.
Thanks for a considerate stream.
Hope you get a good rest after all that recording.
Yeah, I can't wait for you guys to see.
Busy busy recently, because it's been like recording for other stuff.
Then also getting ready for the concert.
Ducky, thanks for the 5 gifted!
It's just been...
Was it for the concert or something else?
Something else.
Whatever could it be?
But you know, obviously busy is good.
Because it's good stuff.
It's just busy busy.
3 hours of something else.
And then... I can't speak.
There's been a lot going on behind the scenes too, so...
I mean, that's generally how it is, right?
I feel... Well, I was gonna say it's been kind of slow.
But maybe not.
You know, have the concert?
I think maybe in terms of announcements.
I don't know.
Solaris!
Welcome to the membo show!
Thank you for the 7 months!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
I don't know.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Let's go, Minto.
What are you thinking for 300k?
I don't know.
Or rather, I think why I say it feels kind of slow is because a lot of stuff I'm working on is not to be known for quite some time.
So, you know.
Feels slow in terms of the right now.
But lots working on.
That's all you have to say?
What was I gonna say?
Oh, 300k.
I don't know.
What should we do, guys?
It was my goal for the end of the year, but I wasn't sure if I was gonna make it so I didn't think about it.
I didn't think about it.
Eat the second donut for 300k.
It'll be bad by then.
Go to Antarctica.
I wish.
Who's cuter?
Katelyn or Snake?
Katelyn.
Katelyn is so cute.
Snake is cute, but like in a different way.
But Katelyn is like just...
It makes my heart ache when I think of it.
When I think of...
When I think of Katelyn, the tears just immediately come into my eyes.
It's just so cute.
It's so cute.
You got one guy in the crying.
Snake is not cute though.
What are you talking about?
Anything can be cute.
It's all about perspective.
It's about finding the things, like the little things that someone does.
Or something does.
That's why people can like look at a robot.
You know those robot dogs?
That like people push over and they like stumble and it's just like...
How cute.
Oh wait, I forgot to exit out the game.
The perspective is cute.
The way Snake repeats things is very cute.
Is Kate Sith a Vtuber?
No!
No, because...
Because he's not digital.
He's like a toy.
I'll set you.
You are cute, Minto.
Only because my mama made me this way.
I don't think I ever put Kaitlin in my party in the original game.
He's alright in the remake.
He's so cute though.
Every moment he's around, I feel better.
Snake is cute indeed, but not as cute as JPEG dog.
Minto is extra cute today.
Just kidding.
I think those robot dogs are cute for real.
They are.
What's something that people don't really typically consider cute, but is very cute?
The way you're so intensely moved by your affection for things, that's cute.
That's a weakness.
Cute is a state of being.
Like being a cute ghost.
You bought Ace Combat 7 because of my tweet?
Good.
Ghosts?
No!
Ghosts are so cute!
Snakes are so cute!
Octopus are so cute!
What are you talking about?
Quasimodo.
This poor guy.
My birthday was yesterday!
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course, boo!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Blue!
What happened in March?
Valentine's day was February.
So excited for new players to jump into my series.
Nine, you're so funny.
There was something you tweeted the other day.
It was like a reply to one of my tweets, so I saw it.
It just made me laugh.
Rika-chan!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
If anybody thinks that I am so into Metal Gear...
They don't know how much Nine is into Ace Combat.
I need to get on your level.
That's so funny.
I love it.
True.
He's always messaging us about it.
What do you mean?
We celebrate Brain Rot.
Yeah, we do.
Yes, we do.
Because we love Brain Rot here.
Sometimes I didn't know I was funny though.
Yeah, you're so funny!
What are you talking about?
You're so funny.
I think you guys are hilarious, honestly.
I feel like you guys make me laugh more than I make you guys laugh.
I feel like you guys are always making me laugh.
You guys are so funny.
No you?
No you.
That's not true.
It is true!
You guys have such funny comments.
I'm always laughing.
I'm glad we have Flynn.
It's reciprocal.
You too?
Who, me?
Yes, you.
I'm sure a few of us are funny, but I don't know about me.
I think you guys are all funny.
If you could hear us laughing, you'd probably go insane.
Oh my gosh.
I did a Patreon stream the other day, right?
Because I'm still behind on streams for the Patreon from the podcast.
Because I suck.
I accidentally made a 32 person lobby.
And it was just chaos.
I was just hearing everybody at once.
It was just everything.
If it makes you laugh, then I'm glad.
Anyways, Ace commenting this.
Funny looking, maybe.
I literally have met you, David.
At Vmuse.
We literally... I literally know what you look like.
I saw pictures of you on Twitter.
Literally.
I'm in danger.
I've met some of you guys.
I have.
And for those who I haven't met yet, I will.
I will.
Good luck.
One day or another.
Not if I don't leave my house.
Why do you think you're safe?
Why do you think you're safe then?
I'm a ghost.
I can literally go into your walls.
But then, isn't that good if I go into your walls?
Like someone asked earlier if I...
If I...
If I saw their water problem.
And I said no.
And I could figure out your electricity too.
I'm putting salt in my walls.
No!
Please don't!
Let me stay there.
It's like when you let in a rat for the winter.
And they hide in your walls because they're cold.
One day I will meet Minto.
Okay, wait a second.
Wait.
You... Okay.
Please PM me Mint Phantom.
If I ever meet you, you have to.
You have to have the balls.
You have to.
You have to tell me that it's you.
You have the balls to have that name.
You have to have the balls to say it to my face too.
You have to.
Sounds like a warning.
Yeah, it really sounds like a threat, honestly.
You have to be like, hey, by the way, Minto.
I have to have a face to the name.
By the way, Minto.
Please PM me.
The fact that some of you guys have such courage to say certain things.
You have to have the courage to say it to my face.
I mean, like in person, you know.
You can't just be a little keyboard guy and be like...
She'll never know what I look like.
No, I have to be able to scan your retinas and be like...
Yeah, I will.
Don't worry.
Okay, good.
Have you gotten to meet EMTA yet?
I haven't.
I want to meet everybody.
If I'm ever at a convention near you...
Please...
Please come say hi.
Oh, sorry.
That was my...
That was my controller.
Which I might be.
Well, I'm not going to be at the Anime Week in Atlanta convention itself.
But I will be in Atlanta and then there might be another East Coast convention that I'll be at...
Shortly after.
Next try, princess.
Have you ever thought of doing some kind of virtual meet and greet?
I have!
I want to do something in VRChat.
I just haven't had the time to do it yet.
But also...
I don't know if like...
If... How to do it.
You know, like if it'd be like a...
Single file, line, everybody kind of thing or...
How, so...
You know, sometimes when I'm bored I upload Ace Combat videos just for fun.
But...
It's more to show my skill, how much it changed.
Ah!
Like a diary.
Someday I will give a drawing to Minto.
I will wait for that day.
I will wait, Cyber.
I drop my spaghetti either way for sure.
I'm always more awkward than you, so don't worry about it.
Mint, do you own a Colt single action army?
Technically no.
I have a wooden revolver, but you know...
Why?
You're...
Not yet.
I want to get one.
I've seen one in Japan, but...
Like, I've gone to the Airsoft store, you know.
Do you have any 2025 conventions scheduled yet?
Not...
Really.
Japan Expo Paris overlaps with Anime Expo, so I'm safe from stinky ghosts for another year.
What makes you think I'm going to Anime Expo?
Only one convention has reached out to me for 2025.
Some other ones I've had to decline, but...
Only one that I think I can maybe do.
I'm not sure.
So, it's not like a matter of me...
Like...
It's not me going to them and being like, please invite me!
It's always like, you know, they have to invite me, so...
Are you going to do cons in Asia?
I would if...
Well, there have been some that have invited me, but the timing has not aligned, you know.
Um...
Like, I was supposed to do one that Doki did recently, but I had to not do it.
The timing was not good for me.
Sometimes...
Sometimes timing does not always work out.
And then also, I went kind of crazy over the summer with conventions, and...
I don't want to say I got burnt out, but I was just like, oh gosh.
I'm going to too many events, I need to stream.
Uh...
Speaking of Airsoft, they make the Mark 23 SOCOM as well.
Would you get one of those too?
Sorry, that's my brain rot.
I want to collect Airsoft stuff, yeah.
I've looked it up, of like, people...
Like, I've seen the Reddit threads that are just like, I want to get this Airsoft in Japan, can I bring it back to America?
So...
And it's fun because some of...
Actually, hold on, let me see.
I don't know if I can show these pictures.
Because every time I go to the Airsoft store, they have like, mirrors on them and stuff, you know.
And I don't want to show you my...
Too much ghostly energy, you know, in the pictures.
Might curse you a little bit.
Might curse you if I show you.
That's Tokyo Game Show.
I probably went after, right?
That's...
Maybe I didn't take pictures last trip.
That's a Shoebill.
That's a Disney.
That's a Anisoma.
That's a mint cafe.
That's fireworks with my friends.
Did I ever tell you guys that?
I went to go see fireworks with some of my friends.
And we rented Yukata.
It was my first time ever doing something like that.
You're so cute.
Can you show off your MGS collection?
I want to!
But I feel that my ghostly energy might show in my cabinet.
The way it is.
Zack, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Maybe not as a video, but I can always post it somewhere, you know?
If I can try and get a good picture.
You have friends?
I know, right?
Crazy.
It was so sweet though.
Well, I think maybe I did post a picture of...
Plushie, tiny Minto.
And the fireworks in the background.
But it's so funny.
Hold on.
I wonder if I have any...
I don't want to show a video and you can hear them though.
Just in case.
But it was funny because the place we went to for the fireworks...
We didn't have a bad spot, but we didn't have a great spot.
And there was like this guy in the background that was on the highway.
Like, he was on the road.
And he just would not shut up the entire time.
He would be like, please don't stop and watch the fireworks.
Please keep going.
Please don't stop and watch the fireworks.
So we just ruined the vibes.
Do you have any tips for cosplayers solo infiltrating Comiket for the first time?
I hope you got your cosplayer ticket.
First off.
And bring a small rolly suitcase to change into and everything.
But also, I plan on bringing...
A lot of people bring small rolly suitcases anyway.
Because...
The doujins...
They get so heavy, you know?
So you want to put them into something.
Will you go to Afkai?
I was thinking of making a trip to America if you are.
I would love to go to Afkai if they have me.
If they have me, then I will go.
Oh, I bet you got a license for that cosplay.
I failed the lottery.
I don't think you can cosplay then.
Because...
I can't believe that Comiket this year is a lottery, first of all.
You can't get your confession to a girl you like interrupted by fireworks because some guy is yapping to get moving.
He is the one interrupting.
Oh my gosh, Tuna, who are you confessing to?
Oh my god.
This is weird.
Is it not normally a lottery?
I would used to buy...
I got my tickets at Melon Books.
I didn't think that Comiket is a lottery.
Can you not just show up and cosplay?
Most events in Japan...
You have to...
If you are planning to cosplay at them...
They don't allow you to wear the cosplay on the train and stuff.
Or rather, they don't want people doing that.
So you have to get a cosplay ticket.
And then you go and you change there.
And then you...
Can have the designated cosplay area stuff.
I don't know, I guess they just discourage...
They just don't want people dressing up on...
Trains.
I guess they think it's a disturbance.
Honestly, I'm like...
I don't...
If you want to embarrass yourself by being in cosplay on the train...
That's...
That's your prerogative.
But I guess...
So many people would do it maybe, right?
I don't know.
I think it's...
A silly rule...
But it is a rule nonetheless, so...
And you don't want to be the foreigner that ruins it for other people.
You know?
So...
You want to...
You don't want to be the person that...
Makes it so that they don't...
That they stop selling foreigner tickets or something like that.
Because of it.
So...
Unfortunately, you just gotta abide by the rules.
I see cosplayers on the bus for western cons.
I know!
In the west, they don't care at all.
Do I need a ticket for the Indy Jones watch?
No!
You should be good, Jordan!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited to watch Indiana Jones.
I'm offended by all the salarymen wearing their suits.
Yeah!
Because it's funny, because...
I mean, you don't often see people in like...
Niche...
Clothes, I guess, on the train.
But you still see it.
So what's the difference between that and cosplay?
Many stalker issues for cosplayers.
So maybe a safety issue.
I never thought of it like that.
Maybe.
And then also, you know, I guess...
Some cosplay can be a little...
A little, you know...
So they're just like...
We don't want that on the trains.
A little spicy.
I got something to recommend if you're interested.
It's Ace Combat 7.
Artbook!
Ace at War.
There's lore from old...
I'm writing it down?
Thank you, Nan.
What's it called?
Wait, hold on.
Ace at War.
I'll get it.
Unleash the horny.
Huh?
What was that?
Please don't watch the fireworks.
Pew!
What was that?
Please stop watching the fireworks.
Please keep moving.
But is it a cosplay if Minto cosplays as Minto?
I don't know.
This is me!
You can't stop my identity!
Sadly, there's only JP version.
The EN version already sold out.
I'll find it.
Somewhere.
But...
Also, if you're cosplaying as Comiket...
If you don't feel comfortable changing in front of people...
Maybe bring like a little...
Set like a...
I don't know how to say it.
Not a tent.
But something like that.
You can set up easily.
So you can hide yourself.
Or maybe...
Yeah, like a partition.
A portable wall.
Something like that.
Because that's how you change.
In a room with everybody.
So...
If you're like...
It's embarrassing.
I mean, there is a girl's section and a guy's section.
But...
A cardboard box.
It could even be a cardboard box.
Are there actual portable changing tents?
Like...
At Comiket?
I tried going to summer Comiket and sitting on asphalt in the hot sun for two hours.
It was true misery.
I believe it.
I don't think I'll ever try for summer Comiket.
I can't...
I don't know.
So...
I have a few circles that I'm wanting to hit up this year.
For winter Comiket.
I want to go to Fuwamoko's mama.
Ikomochi-san.
I want to get their set.
It's very cute.
So I'm gonna try for that.
Obviously, Ayami-mama.
I don't care if she tries to give it to me.
I want to pay for it.
She always tries to just give me stuff.
But I'm like, no.
I'll send her her fan box stuff that comes in the mail.
And I'm like, look Ayami!
I got this.
And she's like, why are you paying for it?
And...
Natsukomi is in a word, moist.
There's a couple other artists.
I don't think they have put up their stuff yet.
Their catalog yet.
So, I will see.
I usually go for Kaori.
Pan.
A few others.
Depends.
You're actually too nice.
Oh yeah, I get stinky.
I don't want to go in the summer.
So...
It's musty.
Yeah.
I'm excited.
Any chance of a holiday matsuri appearance?
Never say never.
Stinky minky.
No!
Blue Archive taking over Comiket.
You know what?
I've never been someone who has been into the popular thing.
You know?
When Genshin was taking over the western conventions and stuff.
I was like...
Not really into it.
But to be a part of the popular thing.
Just feels so good.
Because now I'm like, yeah!
Blue Archive is taking over the Comiket!
Yippee!
Yeah!
It's so fun!
To be part of the popular thing.
And be able to buy things.
Characters that you like.
And things that you want.
And you're just like, wow!
Yeah!
Finally!
So happy.
So I'm glad.
It's nice knowing what the hype is about.
I know.
Hipster minto, but not by choice.
I want to be into the fun, popular stuff.
It's just I...
Somehow get into the not popular stuff.
And now the thing that I like is popular.
And I'm so...
Feels good!
Feels good.
After being into the not popular thing for so long.
I'd love to go to Comiket someday.
It is a fun experience.
It's fun because...
It's just such a...
There's that energy of...
Fans.
Otaku.
Gathered all around.
And then you have like...
Of course I love the doujin stuff.
But also the official stuff is very fun too.
The mainstream glow up.
I'm into the popular stuff right now.
Minto.
Oh yeah, baby.
I'm the popular.
I'm the hot stuff.
Is there official stuff at Comiket?
Yeah, there is.
Yeah, there's an official area.
And there's a...
Of course all of you see the doujin area.
It's all like different halls.
It's all separated into.
Hmm.
Well guys, I'm starting to get sleepy.
And hungry.
So I'm gonna go eat.
And sleep.
Tomorrow.
Indiana Jones.
The game.
But not the game.
We're watching along.
If you are part of membership.
And you want to watch Indiana Jones.
At the same time.
Yeah, I'll eat and sleep at the same time.
I'd win.
Today I watched you...
To the stream.
Wait.
While I watched you stream, so much that I crashed my plane in Project Wingman.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you guys for the stream.
Thank you for being all so considerate.
And allowing me to be so considerate as well.
CC!
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
I'll see you guys when I see you next.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
And I'll see you guys.
I gotta rest my voice.
Since I've been doing so much.
Corki, take off.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Otsumita.
Itterasshai, everybody.
Pyropunk, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Will you be streaming the indie game tomorrow before the watchalong?
I don't know yet.
I have to get it and see if my computer runs it.
Because everyone's just like, Can your computer run it, Mito?
Do you have the specs?
Asakusa!
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
What is this profile picture?
Thanks for the superchat.
It's gigaheavy.
It's like 120 gigs.
It's crazy.
K5, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Is your PC beef?
I've been working on getting parts.
Just in case.
Maybe next year.
If parts get more expensive.
I've been working on getting some stuff.
Just in case.
But...
You're not waiting for the new GPUs?
I haven't gotten that yet.
I just got some new fans.
I got some other stuff.
Joy!
Thank you so much for the 5th day.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Appreciate it.
I'm downloading more RAM.
I gotta get those.
I gotta buy those.
Okay.
See you later.
Thank you everybody.
I will see you guys later.
And see you later.
Bye bye.
Have a good day.
Don't forget about us.
Shut up.
You know what I mean.
Dummies.
I could never.
Bye.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Bye bye.